[AUDIO LOGO]
SPEAKER: Welcome to this
episode of the Click to Deploy
series, where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions
from Google Cloud Marketplace.
In this episode,
I'll show you how
to set up a MongoDB deployment
through the Google Cloud
Marketplace.
MongoDB is a NoSQL
document-oriented database
that stores JSON-like
documents with dynamic schemas.
When you are building
your projects,
you might be interested in
using MongoDB as your database.
Click to Deploy makes it
easy to quickly spin up
a MongoDB database instance.
We'll start by searching for
MongoDB in the GCP Marketplace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you see, we have a
couple options for MongoDB
from different vendors.
You can deploy a
container image of MongoDB
or a virtual machine.
For the purpose
of this tutorial,
let's choose the Google
Click to Deploy, a MongoDB
virtual machine.
We are sent to this
landing page, which
shows some important
information about MongoDB,
like an overview
of what MongoDB is,
details about the virtual
machine and its operating
system, and, most importantly,
the estimated monthly costs
of choosing this solution.
Let's click the Launch button
to start this deployment.
Now we get to choose some
important specifications
for our deployment.
We'll start by naming our
deployment for this video.
We will name it MongoDB-101.
We'll choose the zone.
For this tutorial, I'll
keep the default zone,
then you can decide
on servers here
for this deployment, which
is how many servers you
want to deploy.
I'll choose one.
Next, you can determine your
machine family and the machine
type.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For this demo, I'll
use e2 highmem 4,
which is a high-memory
machine type that
has 8 gigabytes of
system memory per vCPU.
We'll keep the defaults
for boot disk type.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You also have the option
to select Arbiter tier.
Arbiter is a MongoDB instance
that is a part of replica set
but does not hold data,
and is instead used
to participate in elections.
Finally, you can also decide
on additional specifications
like CPU platform, GPU, network
interface, and firewalls.
Now we've completed
the specification.
We'll click the Deploy button.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Great!
So now our MongoDB
VM is deployed,
and now we see the
Deployment Manager.
The Deployment Manager allows
you to create and manage
cloud resources.
Here we see the deployed
MongoDB instance,
which includes files that
show VM instance, disk,
and firewall information.
Now we can test this
MongoDB instance
by running a couple of commands.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So there you have it-- a
MongoDB instance created
with a click of a button.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
If you'd like to
deploy MongoDB VM,
we encourage you to check
out the GCP Marketplace
and deploy the
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]